le père Louis Dassy qui est le fondateur
de la congrégation des sœurs de Marie
Immaculée à laquelle j'appartiens ce
mari benadet préside la toute jeune
association régionale d'Asie qui
signifie développement des actions
spécifiques pour les déficiens
sensorielles ou des îles avec son
expérience acquise pendant les longues
années passées à la direction du centre
de la ressource elle met aujourd'hui en
place un dispositif de formation pour
faciliter la communication avec les
malentendants et les aveugles une action
qui s'étend à l'ensemble des îles de
l'Océan Indien
et pourquoi d'asser merci arrive à la
suite du centre de la ressource que je
viens de quitter en tant que directrice
où j'ai travaillé pendant 10 ans et ces
dernières années je voyais souvent des
jeunes revenir vers nous vers les
professionnels de la ressource alors
qu'ils étaient déjà en poste alors
qu'ils avaient déjà du travail qu'ils
étaient mariés en fait il venait souvent
nous demander de les aider dans la
communication avec la société alors
évidemment des questions nous viennent à
moi surtout je me disais mais comment la
société les accueillent ces jeunes qu'on
a formé qui ont une profession qui se
sont mariées qui essaient de s'installer
et d'avoir une vie personnelle et
professionnelle que fait la société pour
les accueillir c'est malentendants c'est
malvoyants
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire nous aussi
et puis une deuxième question
tentait souvent dans la tête c'est que
j'avais vu un petit peu ce qui se
passait dans les îles voisines et je me
disais si on est né à l'île de la
Réunion et on est aveugle on est sourd
on a droit à un enseignement un
éducation spécialisée dans un centre qui
est le centre de la ressource ou alors
dans les classes de l'éducation
nationale et si on est né dans une île à
une demi-heure à trois quarts d'heure à
une heure deux heures d'ici les enfants
n'ont pas les mêmes droits à la culture
à l'éducation à l'enseignement pourquoi
parce que ils sont dans des pays un
petit peu moins développés sur ce
problème de l'accueil des enfants
handicapés alors vous voyez avec tout ça
on a créé d'assis d'acide depuis l'année
dernière pour essayer de répondre à deux
grandes lignes de questions
de professeurs de langues des signes et
un de braille encadrent les formations à
Dassy Pascal qui est ici le professeur
qui enseigne
Pascal pavlykowski
c'est ça les chefs
a un centre de formation qui cette
maison et dans cette maison chaque
semaine il y a des formations à la
langue des signes d'une part ou des
formations à la lecture et écriture
braille
donc je travaille à la
SHLMR il y a ce pendant quelques
difficultés et quand on va dans des
associations des administrations pour
leur dire combien il est important pour
leur personnel d'être formé à la
communication alors
ce ne sont pas des difficultés au niveau
de la compréhension parce que quand on
est dans les mairies ou des centrales
administratifs tels que la justice la
police etc tout le monde va bien le
besoin d'accord mais après quand il faut
payer la formation pour la personnelle
et bien voilà c'est autre chose c'est
plus long mais nous nous continuons
cette démarche là il faut absolument
qu'on y arrive et que les personnes
sourdes et des personnes aveugles soit
bien accueillis dans les milieux
en tant que citoyen et par exemple dans
les milieux hospitaliers en tant que que
malade et ils ont droit à toutes les
informations etc et souvent dans les
gens ne peuvent pas communiquer avec eux
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y pas vraiment
d'aide mais au fur et à mesure j'espère
qu'on arrivera Antonella a une autre
expérience parce que on est là chante
fait du théâtre alors quand nous avons
annoncé des formations en langue des
signes ou des formations rails nous
pensions nous que ces formations
allaient tout de suite trouver un écho
auprès des professionnels nous avons
pensé également aux parents les parents
des enfants qui ont qui sont à au centre
de la ressource ou alors qui sont à
l'école ordinaire mais qui sont sourds
ou qui sont aveugles nous avons pensé à
tout ce public des entreprises et des
parents et puis à notre grande surprise
nous avons accueilli ici et nous
continuons d'accueillir dans nos
formations des étudiants et là c'est
super parce que ce sont des jeunes qui
sont étudiants en toute branche et qui
qui s'intéresse et qui se disent mais
voilà nous nous voulons communiquer avec
des soirées des aveugles il faut pas
qu'il y ait de différence dans notre
société mais est-ce que sont motivés par
une un mot coucou juste pour pouvoir
partager ce qu'ils ont appris chez vous
ils veulent communiquer ils veulent donc
apprendre pour pouvoir communiquer et
pour pouvoir il y a des étudiants qui
ont dit aussi pour pouvoir aider des
étudiants aveugles ou sourds qui
viendraient à l'université parce qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'aide à leur
disposition et puis on retrouve un peu
la jeunesse avec son idéal c'est à dire
de pouvoir communiquer partout de
pouvoir communiquer de pouvoir rendre
service aux personnes à domicile et je
pense qu'avec ces jeunes là nous avons
des projets par exemple on parle
maintenant d'accueillir pour des loisirs
pendant les vacances pour faire des
découvertes ici de l'île de la Réunion
avec des groupes de jeunes qui seraient
aveugles ou sourds donc des étudiants se
proposent de les accompagner nous avons
également à la suite de tout cet accueil
des étudiants pensaient à Jeunesse et
Sport nous avons un agrément avec
Jeunesse et Sport et nous allons bientôt
là au mois de mars proposez une
formation en BAFA spécialisée alors ça
c'est intéressant parce que tous les
animateurs de centre de colonie de
vacances de centre de loisirs pourraient
s'inscrire pour pouvoir accueillir dans
leur groupe des enfants aveugles des
enfants sourds au même titre que les
autres alors je disais cette jeunesse là
qui est venue demander la formation et
aussi à ma grande surprise mais agréable
surprise des personnes demandeurs
d'emploi des chômeurs qui sont venus
nous dire nous avons du temps alors nous
pouvons nous former à la à la
communication en langue des signes en
braille
pour des enfants soient polis alors avec
illustration vous avez une bibliothèque
de nous avons commencé oui nous avons
déjà des vidéos qui circulent ou nous
racontons des actions qui peuvent aider
des aveugles et des sourds nous avons
aussi commencé une
petite bibliothèque en braille où nous
avons transcrit des livres
qui sont là maintenant à la disposition
des jeunes et des adultes nous avons
créé la bibliothèque sur les comptes des
îles de l'Océan Indien nous avons
transcrit des contes de Mayotte des
comptes des Seychelles des contes de
Madagascar qui sont en braille et qui
sont aussi enregistrées donc une
bibliothèque écrite et sonore il adorait
la musique
nous voulons développer cette communauté
la francophones et nous voulons pouvoir
accueillir dans les mois à venir dans
les années à venir des jeunes aveugles
et sourds des autres pays pourquoi parce
que quand on est dans une île on est
tout seul j'ai vu par exemple l'année
dernière la grande surprise des jeunes
c'est chez loi qui était venues ici deux
jeunes qui étaient venus en formation
leur grande surprise de découvrir qu'il
y avait autant de sourds qui avait une
grande école ici à la Réunion et ils ont
pu rencontrer beaucoup de Sours qui sont
mariés qui ont des enfants etc il disait
mais alors il y a autant de sourds alors
que nous dans notre pays ben bon on
connaît une vingtaine et puis c'est tout
alors ils ont voulu communiquer ils ont
voulu établir des correspondances etc
alors est venu pour nous un projet qui a
vu le jour donc de créer ici à la
Réunion une maison d'accueil et
d'échanges pour des sourds et des
aveugles des îles de l'Océan Indien dans
le pays pour suivre toujours tous les
niveaux nous avons un comité d'assis
alors il y a le comité d'assis
Seychelles il y a le comité d'Acima Yod
va être créé bientôt le comité d'acim
Madagascar ce sont ces comités qui sont
en relation avec nous mais dans ces
pays-là donc il y a des gens qui
composent le bureau pour que nous nous
soyons pas comme ayant même mis dans
leur pays non c'est un idéal aussi de
notre association de respecter l'être de
respecter la personne dans tout ce qui
fait sa culture dans tout ce qui fait
son appartenance à son pays nous nous
sommes que des partenaires techniques
nous apportons nos compétences mais nous
respectons le rythme du pays
alors personnel de Dassy il y a Odile
prevoto
mais il y a un autre partage humain qui
se fait c'est à dire quand nous arrivons
comme ça dans les îles évidemment nous
prenons le programme scolaire du pays
les programmes pédagogiques nous nous
enrichissons aussi parce que ils ont des
méthodes de travail que nous n'avons pas
ils ont aussi du matériel que nous
n'avons pas et nous apportons également
du matériel spécialisé qu'ils n'ont pas
et puis d'autres fois comme pour
Madagascar il faut apporter un peu plus
bon il y a les côtés instances
techniques d'accord il y a le matériel
spécialisé mais il y a aussi toutes
toutes l'aide humanitaire qu'on peut
apporter et ça c'est formidable parce
que la dernière fois l'argentier comme
quand nous sommes allés à Madagascar les
gens de la petite association de
Madagascar nous disait si vous pouviez
nous apporter aussi à manger un peu de
vêtements un peu d'autres choses quoi et
nous avons fait appel aux membres de
l'association ou à nos amis et nous
sommes partis et là nous avons eu et je
dois le dire et souligner l'action
complémentaire de l'armée c'est ce sont
les militaires qui nous ont aidés dans
le transport et nous avons pu comme ça
aller en mission à trois personnes
gratuitement transportées par l'armée
pendant 8 jours et nous avons apporté
452 kg de matériel et de vivre pour
Madagascar alors ça c'est vraiment
formidable parce que avec nous il y a
d'autres qui se mettent en route et qui
apportent bénévolement leur aide et leur
savoir et puis leur avoir aussi pour
être au service des autres mais comment
sont financer ces actions justement
ces actions ne sont pas encore financées
par l'État pour le moment nous avons des
aides au niveau des personnels d'ici
mais nos actions sont financées par des
cotisations que nous avons par des
petites subventions des particuliers ou
alors par des formations que nous
faisons ici à l'île de la Réunion des
formations qui sont payantes nous avons
existence que depuis un an un an de
fonctionnement mais déjà je vois des
gens qui qui viennent et qui nous aident
est-ce qu'il y a ici à Dassy c'est c'est
une famille qui est en train de se créer
là il y a vraiment les anniversaires se
fêtent ici maintenant il y a des
étudiants qui de temps en temps on passe
et disent nous avons invité des amis et
nous voulons venir ici à Dassy pour
faire connaissance etc donc il y a une
vie de famille qui se crée et je trouve
que c'est intéressant c'est important
pour garder toujours ce côté humain